tell me about you know the process
of starting hook probe and really what
inspired it
i have been a lactation consultant in
las vegas for
15 years and so because of that i'm in
like
every mommy group and like you know i
give advice in the groups and that kind
of stuff
and so i noticed especially once our
lockdown began
that a lot of people were posting about
i can't afford my diapers we don't have
any work we still don't have our
unemployment
we i can't afford wipes i can't afford
my formula
like my insurance companies taking
forever with my breast pump
over and over and over and over and over
and
you know moms all over the city were
like i have this you can come get this
my baby outgrew this you can come get
that but that meant people literally
driving all over town
and i said you know what everybody knows
me like i'm
i'm trusted people aren't going to feel
nervous about coming to my house and i
said why don't i just do like a drop-off
point is how it started
and i thought i can just be like a
clearing house right so i said bring me
what you don't need
and then people who need it can pick it
up from my house just free just come get
it if you need it right
so that's how it started diapers and
wipes and formula and pumps and
it was very very basic right um baby
cereal baby food like
really minimal stuff and a bunch of
postpartum supplies so
menstrual supplies things like that for
right after you have a baby and
it just exploded
so we did an amazon wish list um we have
an amazon wishlist under hope cove
and it was this vehicle
for people to donate from afar even we
had an anonymous donor in our first
couple of months that donated almost ten
thousand dollars in merchandise for us
went to our amazon wishlist bought one
of everything that was their first act i
have no idea who it was
none but that literally gave us the
push to really get us started
and we i opened the facebook page and
just started posting and started sharing
and all the mom groups and then
it just it snowballed it just grew and
grew and grew
soon we were bursting out of my house i
have a tiny little house that's only 300
square feet
i was using the space behind my couch
between my couch and my back door
i bought this shelving that you see
behind that was all behind my shelf my
couch and that's where everything was
stacked to the ceiling
my breakfast nook full of postpartum
supplies
like i was bursting so my friends
claire and tyson green have these spaces
here
and they said you know what we have two
spaces that are not in use
and we would love to donate them to you
so that you can move hope cove
out of your house oh my gosh what
so we came in it kind of looked like
county jail in here when we first
got here um it was
like a really dirty white kind of paint
and
in very 70s you know we got the surprise
we don't have popcorn ceilings
but they were like you can paint it
whatever you want you know and so we had
great volunteer effort the main ones
were our friends luis and annie
hernandez they
really came through they helped us paint
we had
paint donors lowe's was actually
beautiful to us they gave us a beautiful
discount on
all the paint that we needed saved us a
ton of money
and everybody just kind of came together
so it took about two and a half weeks or
so
got everything moved everything over
from the house my house can breathe
again
and here we are so it's the goal is to
just grow and grow and grow and reach
as much of our community as we can after
being involved with so many groups with
local mothers and
you know how does it feel to one see
them struggling so much
but then also how does it feel to be
able to help them
during a time when so many people need
assistance
it's aside from lactation consulting
which has been my passion for
20 years it's probably the single most
fulfilling thing outside of my own
motherhood that i've ever done
it's i'll tell you the craziest thing
that ever
came to my front door was a teenage
momma and she had her little baby with
her and her baby was wearing
hand to god paper towels wrapped in
cling wrap
for a diaper i cried for 20 minutes
after she left it ripped my heart out of
my chest
i said how long has it been like that
she was like three days somebody shared
hope cove with me
in a facebook message and that's why how
i found out about you
the problem is there's other programs in
town that
offer assistance to people with small
children but there's a lot of qualifiers
there's paperwork there's birth
certificates needed there's id
needed there's proof of financial need
that has to be given
so there's a lot of that going on and i
understand those policies because
you get ripped off and we've been ripped
off
right by scammers coming to the door and
we've gotten a lot wiser to it now so
good luck but um i understand those
programs because they're protecting
the inventory from people who don't
actually need it right
but the problem is
you have people that fall through those
cracks you have people who are coming
out of homelessness who have no
paperwork whatsoever no identification
people coming out of domestic violence
that literally
grabbed their kids and ran they have
nothing
people coming from homelessness people
who live in weeklies people who live in
motels
people living with family they just
cannot supply those things
so for those people i founded hope cove
because i wanted everyone to be able to
have access to what they needed
without jumping through a million hoops
sure so and what exactly are those
um i guess qualifiers or lack of for
for hope club people need help and they
want to come here they just come
they literally just come it's uh we're
looking for our 501c3 is almost done
uh we're about halfway there we're
officially an entity and we're almost
done
that service was also donated to us by a
very
giving attorney that is helping us to
get that done properly
um and so for us we just said
you know we want it to be as easy as
possible we want people to just come and
knock on the door
and we are completely and utterly
reliant on donations both financial and
physical items which is why we have our
wish list on
amazon and then hopefully once our 501c3
is completed
then we can seek out grants and
corporate donors and things like that so
that's what we're really looking forward
to
people want to get involved to help you
what should they do you mentioned the
amazon wishlist
so we have our amazon wishlist um we
that has everything on it that we give
out on the regular
we also accept donations from families
so if your baby has grown out of diapers
and you have two boxes of the old size
bring them on over you want to stop over
to target grab us a case of wipes
you know send formula whatever people
don't understand that i literally take
everything so if you have an open box of
diapers i'll take the open box if you
have a diaper cake that you got for your
shower
and you don't want to take that diaper
cake apart send it to me i'll take it
apart we'll give it to people
um the we have on facebook we have a
group called hope coves volunteer
village
if you want to physically volunteer and
work in the shop or do pickups for us of
larger donations
um join hope coast volunteer village and
you can get involved
in person like we'd love to have you
we'd love to have you what's next for
you
what do you wish for hope code when you
think from a year from now where do you
where do you want to be
i want to be in a larger location so
that we can expand our inventory
and i would like to be in a couple
different parts of town so i would
really like to
have something i mean we're over here on
the east side by boulder station
i would love to have something further
south i would like to have something
in the north end just because a lot of
the people that we serve have no
transportation
they're on buses they're something i've
had people walk
when we were at my house just a little
quip we were at my house which is off
jones and charleston i had a young lady
that lives
she has moved now but she lived in a
weekly by sam's town
she walked from sam's town to my house
with a two-month-old baby in a stroller
and her service dog
that's how far she walked like it's
insane it's 12 miles she
came got to my house at 11 30 at night
the only reason i knew she was there is
because my daughter
called my cell phone from her bedroom
and said mom there's a baby crying on
the porch
what so covet or no covid we were like
please come in sit down we fed her like
she nursed the baby we let the dog sleep
for a little while and then we drove
them home like
but like that's what's important for us
to be able to expand and get into more
than one location
the other thing is we want to expand
into future cities
that is really our goal is to expand
even outside of nevada
so my nephew in snohomish washington
is almost an eagle i'm very proud of him
he's on his final project for eagle
scout
he has decided just out of their garage
to open hope cove snohomish in snohomish
washington
so they're currently taking donations to
be able to open up
there in the middle of snohomish so
it's just like it has the potential to
really expand and get bigger and that's
really what we would love to see
happen how big is the need there are
still people waiting for unemployment
that filed in march um people are living
on nothing
they're living on nothing like i have
i'm sure you'll get footage of it but
like i have things like
shampoo conditioner body wash i have
menstrual products i have things that
people literally have no money for
if i had room for toilet paper i'd carry
that too
you know but it's just the the we
thought
if we get a little further and when the
lockdown eased a little bit and some of
our casino
workers went back to work and some of
our bar workers got to go back to work
we thought oh maybe things will slow
down but for the community that we serve
no like the need is just
it's massive it's massive and we've had
times where we've had to close
uh we got a coveted exposure one time
and had to close i mean you got to do
what you got to do
right oh my goodness our inbox was
exploding during that time people saying
when are you opening when are you
opening how much longer how much longer
like and it breaks my heart so right now
we're only closed on sundays because
my volunteers need a break but we're
open six days a week
and we have long hours uh monday through
friday we're open from ten until seven
and on saturdays we're open from ten
until five and it's literally
just come ring the doorbell knock on the
door
somebody will open the door you let us
know what you need
it's that simple people are not allowed
to come inside hope cove
because of covet 19 restrictions so we
want to really limit the amount of
bodies that are in here
and my volunteers follow very strict
guidelines as far as their masking and
they're wiping things down and they're
sanitizing so
to keep everyone safe and to keep the
inventory safe we don't allow people to
come in and shop
but you shop at the door so let us know
what you need we'll fill the bag and
whatever we can give wonderful is there
anything else that you want to add about
hope cove anything i didn't ask about
that's important to get across
um i think the main thing to understand
is that we
are here for everybody so not just
mothers
if you are a single dad if you're a
couple if your grandparents raising
grandchildren
there's a lot of that here there's a lot
of people that are
struggling with addiction and so their
children are not with them they're with
their grandparents they're with their
auntie and uncle people that were not
set up to raise a child you know we have
people that come to us from the foster
kinship program where someone in the
family is lost to addiction and they're
taking care of babies and they're like
oh my god
i have a three month old baby i have
nothing right they come to the door
we help so we're here for everybody
lgbtq
every race every nationality every
religion like
we don't care knock on the door we got
you